if we ask people
which image they most associate with
love there's no question that the
valentine heart would top the list but
what is this link
is it real
or purely metaphorical as a heart
specialist I'm here today to tell you
that this link is very real fear and
grief for example can cause profound
cardiac injury the nerves that control
unconscious processes such as the
heartbeat can sense distress and trigger
a maladaptive fight or flight response
that triggers blood vessels to constrict
the heart to gallop and blood pressure
to rise resulting in damage in other
words
it is increasingly clear
that our hearts are extraordinarily
sensitive to our emotional system